now the government's always insisted it
was following the science on coronavirus
but in recent weeks the economy has also
had a big impact on decisions as well in
just a few days time pubs and
restaurants across the UK will start to
reopen and on Tuesday the Prime Minister
will make a major speech about the
economic recovery so is the sounds still
the guiding principle let's try and find
out we're joined by a sir mark wall port
to with the government's chief
scientific adviser for four years and
who sits on the sage Advisory Committee
thank you very much for being on the
show well as I just said the reopening
of the hospitality sector of
non-essential businesses has already
begun some scientists are split on
whether they think it's a good idea how
comfortable are you with the idea that
the economy does seem to be slowly being
reopened well I mean the economy is as
critical for health as anything else and
so it's been a fine balancing act all
along and so there are health harms from
a damaged economy from people being out
of work and so one's got to balance the
managing the corona virus pandemic
controlling it but also keeping the
economy going at the same time that of
course some people are worried that by
reopening shops pubs restaurants we
could actually be pushing up the rate of
transmission which could lead to another
spike damaging to the economy too and
we'll talk more about the reopening of
schools in the programme is that
something else that could push up the
rate of transmission well I mean again
it's about how you open up the economy
whilst managing to maintain as much
social distancing as you possibly can
and so it's why staying apart keeping
the numbers of people low in shops for
example wearing masks if you're going to
be in close proximity all of those
things really matter and so it's this
balance between getting things going but
making sure that people take personal
responsibility because at the end of the
day it's down to each of us as
individuals to use our sense to try and
reduce social contact as much as
possible it's that balance all along and
is the balance right at the minute
um well I mean the answer is that where
the science comes in is that there's
very close monitoring going on all of
the time and what the office for
national statistics data shows that at
any one time in England at the moment
there are around 1100 people infer
actively infected there are about 3,000
new cases a day across England with some
similar proportions across the whole of
the UK and we know that there are about
890 cases confirmed by testing each day
so the virus is out there it is very
widely distributed and we have to have
conservationists and so it also depends
on people if they get the symptoms if
they get high fever is they get
persistent cough if they lose their
taste or smell then they've got to use
their sense and isolate themselves and
their contacts have to isolate as well I
mean when you read out those figures it
does feel like we have a relatively high
prevalence of the virus still among us
and if the isolation is to work like you
say we also need a really effective a
track and trace system where people are
being tested and then their contacts
traced are you are you confident of that
it's working as it should well I mean
the numbers speak for themselves the
numbers are building up so I've got the
numbers here between the 11th and the
17th of June there were multiplying up
those 890 cases about just over 6,000
that were tested and they managed to
reach 70% of those and about 75% of
those the the the 4870 gave details of
contacts but I mean the others it's not
a perfect system it's not perfect
anywhere in the world and it does depend
as I say on people being sensible and
responsible sensible and responsible and
of course I've taken that responsibility
seriously and do you feel that a second
spike is inevitable inevitable is a very
strong word and it depends what one
means by a second spike because I think
the other thing that's coming clear now
is that when outbreaks occur they
typically occur in clusters and we're
seeing certain work environments for
example food processing factories as
being fairly common places for those
clusters to ride
rise in Korea they found for example in
places of worship that clusters have
risen and if you like and the common
denominator is really being indoors
being crowded or being there for
prolonged periods of time as if noisy
environments where people are coughing
and shouting and so there's more droplet
transmission and so again it come back
to local control being really important
to identify those clusters when they
happen and clamp down on them quickly so
the answer is that we need to do
everything we possibly can to avoid a
widespread second wave the evidence that
the virus does transmit better and Co
workplaces again suggest that winter
might be quite a risky time again yeah I
wanted to pick up on that because I was
really struck by the number of cases
that seemed to be being found at these
food processing plants these factories
where there are of course refrigerated
temperatures do you think that could be
a real warning sign that this could come
back in winter at a time when the NHS is
already under more pressure that is
obviously a significant risk and what's
probably happening is that in these cold
probably slightly damp environments as
well the virus which requires probably a
bit of moisture and enveloped RNA virus
to survive just last longer in the air
and on surfaces in cold wet environment
but of course it is an additional
problem winter because that's the time
when there are other viruses so there's
nothing particularly unusual in corona
virus in that respect but it's the time
when flu comes on the scene and all the
other coughs and colds and sneezes that
we get in which time and now you of
course have been looking at the hunt for
vaccine as well I remember those
headlines saying one might be ready by
September which feels quite optimistic
now what is the current situation on the
hunt for a vaccine and when do you think
one could be available I mean the
current situation is that there are
vaccines around the world and I mean the
UK is one of the global leaders in this
and two of the vaccines one from Oxford
and one from Imperial College are now
going into clinical trials and we're
also in a position potentially to
manufacture these at large scale but the
answer is that before you vaccinate at
the level of
halation you need some evidence that the
vaccine works and also that there are no
unforeseen harmful side effects as far
as possible and so in terms of
large-scale vaccine vaccinations that's
extremely unlikely until next yeah but
there may be very significant trial
starting from now through to the autumn
say there you say there of course were
still learning about this new virus what
immunity will have how long that will
last for you know is there a chance that
we may not actually get a vaccine at all
for coronavirus that works effectively
and could this be something that you
think that we'll always be living with
nothing is guaranteed but there is
natural immunity to this virus in the
sense that people's immune system does
actually bring it under the control so
the very fact that we get better is
because our immune system is responding
and so I think you know we would be
unlucky if there wasn't a vaccine that
worked eventually but nothing in life is
absolutely guaranteed and of course I
mean the other thing that UK is actually
doing well in globally is around the
research on the clinical treatments that
work and so the recovery trial at trial
which has been jointly funded by the
National Institute of Health Research in
the Box Health and Social Care and UK
research innovation has shown for
example that dexamethasone which is an
anti-inflammatory steroid has a
significant effect in reducing mortality
in patients with severe disease now it
isn't a magic bullet and we don't have a
perfect antiviral agent yet but we have
to take all the approaches and so we
need not only put all our effort into
vaccine development but also into
developing new drugs new antiviral
agents new agents that might deal with
the sort of the lethal second phase of
the infection that unfortunately affects
a small but important minority of people
now just finally mmm of course we'll be
looking back it's the response to copa90
did in many years time we wouldn't have
a clear picture until then but it does
look as if the UK could be on course to
have a higher death toll and a worse
economic hit potentially a longer
lockdown than some of our European
neighbors now there will of course be
criticism directed at the government for
its response but I just wonder whether
british scientists needs to share some
of that responsibility too just looking
at you know some of these sage committee
advice in february sage saying that
where there is sustained transmission in
the UK contact tracing will no longer be
useful and Prevention of mass gatherings
wouldn't be effective as when in
limiting transmission on the 10th of
march saying public gatherings posed a
relatively low public risk I mean do you
accept that on cope at 19 it does seem
that scientists in the UK have got
something's wrong I think that you know
the retrospective is a very very
powerful instrument as I said before and
I think that there will be plenty of
time to look at enquiries I think that
you know did the UK lock down a bit
later than it should I think history
will probably show that it did but I
think we're talking about you know
decisions of days and the scientific
advice was always very strongly to test
and I think that one of the other things
that will need to be looked at later is
the whole sort of logistics and response
and how much as it were the UK and other
countries paid in the insurance policies
in advance to protect against pandemics
it was the top thing and still is the
top thing on the UK's national risk
register and I think that what history
will also show is that those countries
that had experienced previous very nasty
pandemics or bizarre epidemics of
infection have been better prepared and
so it was in Korea that they had an
outbreak of the MERS coronavirus which
is if it can be imagined very much worse
than actually they coded 19 crises that
were going through at the moment the
countries that had bird flu the
countries that had SARS the first sort
of variant of this were all better
prepared and I think that that's one of
the important lessons which is that we
need to worry a bit more about the next
emergency as well as actually being well
compared for the last one yeah very
quickly and because it's been very
interesting hearing what you said do you
think the government has been listening
to the science I think the government
have been listening to the sounds
throughout and but it comes back to your
first question actually which is a
of the day the policymakers and it's not
the scientists who make the policy it is
entirely politicians who are the
policymakers they've had to balance a
series of very difficult but completely
issues which is the major harms that
occur to society if supply lines break
down for example if transport systems
break down and all of the effects on the
economy and you know schools is another
example where we know that children will
come to harm if they miss out on their
education for a prolonged period
I'm afraid it's you know much easier to
be the scientific advice of them is to
be the policy maker